le sens de l'action du gouvernement
merci Madame la parole est à Monsieur
Bernard
Peru monsieur le Premier ministre à
l'aveille du débat d'orientation des
finances publiques il est temps de dire
la vérité aux Français la cruelle vérité
du dérapage de nos finances publique
celle d'un gouvernement incapable de
tenir ses engagements pour l'avenir de
notre pays la Cour des comptes le
rappelle dans son rapport sur les
perspectives de finances publiques
l'absence de réformes structurelles
combinée à la multiplication des
dépenses nouvelles rendent très
incertain l'objectif que le déficit
passe sous la barre des 3 % du PIB en
2017 la France présente aujourd'hui l'un
des pires résultats en Europe sur la
maîtrise de ces dépenses avec votre
distribution de cadeaux et toutes vos
promesses les dépenses nouvelles non
financées les dépenses nouvelles non
financées atteignent déjà en cumulé près
de 10 milliards d'euros en années
pleines qui risque de de peser encore
beaucoup plus un risque majeur sur nos
finances publiques en
2017 et le matraquage fiscal que nous
dénonçons depuis 2012 vient d'être
confirmé par la rapporteur générale du
budget cette semaine qui révèle que les
ménages sont les plus grands perdants du
quinquena avec un choc fiscal de plus de
50 milliards d'Ô supplémentaires depuis
juillet
2012 aujourd'hui mes chers collègues les
masques tombent vous venez d'enterrer
l'objectif d'économie sur la période
2015-27 absence de réforme structurelle
dérapage des dépenses matraquage fiscal
objectif d'économie de déficit non
atteint c'est le résultat d'une
politique irresponsable vous
compromettez aujourd'hui la santé
financière de la France pour les années
qui viennent c'est grave très grave
alors Monsieur le Premier Ministre quel
sera le montant exact de l'ardoise que
vous allez laisser à vos successeurs la
note sera lourde ce sera celle de
l'échec et de la puissance merci la
parole est à Monsieur Christian Ecker
secrétaire d'État chargé du budget
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
Péru la passion n'exclut pas la raison
on appelle un peu plus de mesure quant
aux chiffres que vous évoquez il y en a
un certain nombre qui mériterait débat
et je vous donne rendez-vous demain je
suis sûr que vous serait là au débat
d'orientation des finances publiques
monsieur le député ne confondait pas le
chemin et l'objectif l'objectif c'est de
rester en dessous de 3 % de déficit en
2007 cet objectif est maintenu et
d'ailleurs j'observe que pour 2016 même
la Cour des comptes c'est peut dire ne
remet pas en cause l'objectif de 3,3 %
de déficit je vous rappelle quand même
que le chemin trouve son origine à
5,1% c'est l'ardoise puisque vous en
parlez que vous nous avez laissé alors
si l'objectif est maintenu le chemin lui
doit s'adapter monsieur le député quand
il y a de nouveaux obstacles sur le
chemin quand nos armées sont engagées
plus que d'habitude à l'extérieur
lorsqu'une crise agricole nécessite des
mesures immédiates lorsque le terrorisme
justifie que nous renforcions des moyens
que vous aviez la se dégrader lorsque le
besoin de financement de formation et de
financement de l'embauche dans les PME
se fait jour il faut parfois modifier le
chemin et utiliser les économies sur la
charge de remboursement de la dette les
économies sur le moindre coût pardon des
contentieux fiscaux que vous nous aviez
laissé utiliser les produits supérieurs
à ce que vous réalisiez de la lutte
contre la fraude que vous envisagez
d'ailleurs d'abandonner ou quasiment
dans vos programmes c'est bien entendu
c'est bien entendu à s'assurer que le
chemin sera suivi avec détermination il
y en a qui courent dans tous les sens
nous c'est avec détermination